jetzt sollte es aber eigentlich wieder gehen ja jetzt geht's wieder ja da hat sich der hat sich
im prinzip auch reconnected aber das dauert wohl ein bisschen ok und jetzt kopieren wir das mal
rüber wie schnell sind wir jetzt ok hey leute wir sind schon mal besser oder 300 400 mb die
sekunde ok da kämpft jetzt geht's runter der cash ist wahrscheinlich jetzt voll oder so
oh was das hier oh ziemlich mies
was war denn das jetzt
also 10 gigabit stelle ich mir anders vor warum meckert die windows fireball ich habe keine ahnung
ach so ja wahrscheinlich weil chrome nicht drauf zugreifen weil das ein neues weil das wenn die
windows fireball merkt merkt sich doch dass das interface worüber das geht ich mein guckt mal
auf der ssd selbst ist es saumäßig schnell da flutscht es kann es sein dass mein cash einfach
voll war ok wir testen mal was wir testen mal was wir testen mal was shares
jetzt hat die vm natürlich kein internet kein netzwerk mehr
jetzt hat die vm natürlich kein netzwerk mehr weil wo ging das noch mal settings
ne wo macht man netzwerk wir virtual network editor bridge network aber wo stellt man den
krempel dann noch mal im noch mal um wo sagt man ihm noch mal welches netzwerk er verwenden
soll für in krempel der kann auch nut verwenden ist mir egal hauptsache netzwerk technisch geht
wieder netzwerk unreachable was auch immer ok wunderbar geht wieder gut was hat er für schmerzen
wobei der ssd mit 4 mb kann er kann er kann er schlecht sein ok jetzt ist er hä warum ist
es so langsam das kann doch nicht in ernst sein am anfang war es schnell am anfang hat
es geflutscht also an der netze an der netze am netzwerk kann es ja auch schlecht liegen
ok kommt heute wieder da vielleicht ja ok cash no use cash pool no apply das sind das sind
intel server ssd die ich da drin hatte zwar ein bisschen älter aber die werden nicht
4 mb aufschreiben haben gut jetzt gehts runter auf die geschwindigkeit von der festplatte
das lag aus irgendwelchen gründen am cash aber wie kann das am cash liegen wie kann
das ich meine das ist immerhin ssd cash ganz so beschissen ist es jetzt auch wieder net
so das ist jetzt direkt auf die platten alles klar so main nee cash pool ist hier 0w nix
drauf airflow temperature ja ist älter was das ist ja ist ja ätzend so kann man irgendwie
performance tests machen wie schnell das eigentlich ist kann man irgendwie so ein benchmark
machen oder sowas ok wir testen jetzt noch mal shares cash prefer cash apply
älter mit dem cash ist das abfahrt langsam warum
das ist super krass langsam mit dem cash no ja gut
geh mal auf settings scheduler dann cash nee gibts nicht es darf nicht so langsam sein
schreib ich also das vielleicht liegt das wirklich an den ssd man kann doch hier oben
irgendwo auf platte ok kann man direkt auf den pool drauf auf den cash drauf mnt cash
1 m 1 ok direkt auf den direkt auf den cash pv ist pv drauf sehr schön hat def 0 nach
pv null punkt bin ok die ssd sind im arsch oder was möchte mir das sagen das kann doch
nicht sein dass die ssd so langsam sind was soll denn das sein was ist denn das
ein mienbord ist kaputt ich habe doch jetzt auch eine neue ip oder sehr leute ich habe
eine neue ip bekommen habe ich denn für eine ip jetzt 130 ip oh nein ok aus irgendwelchen
gründen sind meine ssd fucking langsam aber so langsam können die doch gar nicht sein
so main was sieht man denn was es ist es sind cash mtf dings da kriegt man auch bestimmt
raus was es für ssd sind wie gesagt das sind alte intel server ip alte intel server ssd
ok und was was erfahre ich jetzt was da drinne ist vielleicht sind die dinger wirklich so
wahnsinnig geil mit mit 4 mb die sekunde hat jemanden klotten in der clever idee wie
ich raus bekomme was da wirklich dahinter steckt datenblatt sata wie die zinger sind
richtig alt die sind zehn jahre alt oder so die habe ich mal abgestaubt umsonst ok
die ssd sind abfang langsam ok ich habe eine idee wir machen andere ssd rein kein nvm wir
machen andere ssd rein ich wusste es nicht als schermer und guck mal ich habe doch gerade
auf die ssd geschrieben so schnell wie geht und auf die ssd schreiben die ssd sind rip
die ssd sind einfach komplett kaputt kannst du vergessen so wie entferne ich denn den
cash pool wieder cash pool gar nicht stop proceed
ich mache jetzt keine ssd analysi steckt halt andere ssd rein und gut ist ok das hängt
ok das liegt definitiv an den ssd ich habe hier noch eine andere ich habe hier noch eine
wo ist die dann mensch einer ich finde hier seitdem ich aufgeräumt ich hatte die gestern
ich habe die gestern eben hingelegt aber was ist das warum ist alles weg was ich suche
ja ist irgendwie weg
ich habe gestern einen in der hand gehabt weil ich mir gedacht habe die kann ich für
mein android zeug verwenden und ich bilde mir ein ich habe die einfach hier neben mir
auf den rechner gelegt aber habe ich anscheinend nicht oder moment mal unten drunter gucken
ah hier unterm switch man unterm switch ok leute ich glaube ich glaube die ssd sind
gerade verreckt ich glaube die ssd sind gerade verreckt vorbei so das heißt ich stöpsel
jetzt mal ab können wir uns gleich mal gucken was passiert wenn ich im laufenden betrieb
die ssd rausziehe wobei komm wir schalten wir schalten aus komm wir sind nett wir schalten
aus wir schalten aus wie geht denn das hier power maintenance ne wie macht man hier strom
aus meine güte warum ist das so configuration warum ist das so wir muss sich einen knopf
geben ich kann euch sein dass ich diesen mist hier aufmachen muss dafür um auszuschalten
ok das muss man wohl im firefox machen weil es woanders nicht funktioniert hat jetzt
ist array gestoppt nein remote control launch aber ne firefox muss ich aufmachen geb ihm
auf login kannst du das nicht in android selber wahrscheinlich aber android selber ist
gerade am abkacken weil meine ssd wohl verreckt sind oder so keine ahnung launch so das hässliche
java ding wieder aufmachen da steht doch shutdown chat was habe ich gerade gesagt was habe
ich gerade gesagt so aus was habe ich gerade gesagt so aus jetzt ist die kiste ich habe
gerade gesagt android hängt weil mir die ssd verreckt sind da wird es bestimmt nicht
shutdown machen ohne die fallsysteme gesunken zu haben so ich tausche jetzt mal aus ich
tausche jetzt mal diese ssd aus gegen ne mx 500 ssd und dann probieren wir das noch mal
mal gucken wobei machen wir anders wir booten das noch mal wir booten das noch mal und gucken
was passiert ob das jetzt hoch kommt mit kaputtem cash dass du hast recht sysrq echo sysrq trigger
hätte auch funktioniert da habe ich gar nicht dran gedacht da habt ihr recht ja das ist
richtig wobei ist das echo o echo o ist power off und echo b ist glaube ich reboot ne sysrq
trigger reboot das ist auch das ist auch nice wenn server hängt bam direkt stecker ziehen
mal gucken ob der das mit den booten übrigens checkt wenn ich nix mache hoffen wir mal
dass das so kapiert ah er checkt es nice du du du das kann ich mir nicht merken kelmor
dass ich kenne das aber ich kann mir das immer nicht merken ich mache am besten wenn
cell noch geht sagst du echo es gibt ja zwei verschiedene sachen du kannst ja hart ausschalten
und du kannst hart reboot und das hat reboot ist auf jeden fall die bessere variante weil
sonst ist halt aus und du kommst nicht wieder dran so schau mir mal was passiert
schauen wir mal was passiert wenn er jetzt bootet was dann was er dann macht ob er das
checkt wo ist er jetzt hier gerade dabei sas controller blablabla sys rsyslogd sollte
ich denke ich bald mal gestartet sein wenn mir immer jupu zapp aber das nicht merken
deine schrause so da sind wir wieder ok ja nice gut wir sind wieder am start wie kriege
ich wie kriege ich den cash pool wieder weg no device no device wie kriege ich den cash
pool wieder abgewöhnt ich will ich will den cash entfernen mein cash entfernen muss ja
möglich sein mann achso ok das ist tatsächlich nicht schlecht null ok gut nice gut jetzt
stopp licht die ssd mal dran
ich war jetzt auch noch so ordentlich können euch das vorstellen habt die ssd in dem wechselrahmen
festgeschraubt jetzt kann ich noch nicht mal einfach die ssd tauschen ist die schraube
fest alter was habe ich da gemacht monka ok ich brauche ein bisschen größere größere
geschütze
ok so ich werde mal ssd abschrauben und dann die neue rein machen ja jetzt geht es
auch auf den akkuschrauber habe ich tatsächlich hier daneben stehen ja theoretisch hätte
ich im akkuschrauber raus machen kann aber an so ein bisschen filigranere sachen gehe
ich lieber schraubenzieher oder schraubenzieher jetzt kommt die erste mit der 9 max ist dann
schraubendreher gut ssd ist ab neue ssd drauf die wechselrahmen sind halt nicht gemacht
für ssds eigentlich so schraube rein ich will das unbedingt mit dem cache testen ob
sich das wirklich lohnt weil wenn sie habt ihr das hat es einer von euch im einsatz mit
einem cache weil im zweifelsfall könnte ich mir auch vorstellen da irgendein nvme cache
oder sowas rein zu ploppen gerade wenn man 10g interface hat stelle ich mir das eigentlich
ganz nice vor mit einem ssd cache
das lebe der hotswap rahmen bringt das hier überhaupt was hat das jetzt erkannt dass hotswap
ist hat er jetzt überhaupt erkannt dass es hotswap kommt mal nach er hat es direkt erkannt
sehr schön die hier werde ich für nix verwenden addpool cache und zwar die da und das hier
kommt wieder weg so cache den kram haben wir und start so die ssd hier die werde ich gleich
in müll verfrachten starting services jawoll gib ihm ne zfs würde ich auch nicht verwenden
das habe ich eine weile gehabt mit ubuntu unterbau drinne das ist cool die sache ist
nicht damit muss man sich beschäftigen unmountable format habe ich jetzt gelernt einfach immer
format drücken so und jetzt machen wir gleich noch mal den pool und gucken wie schnell es
jetzt ist und zack da sind wir share und jetzt noch mal unser ubuntu iso rüber ja das gefällt
mir doch schon deutlich besser das sieht doch schon mal besser aus
herr leute das ist doch schon mal besser oh jetzt flutscht es aber ja das finde ich schön
so und das spricht wenn die ssd voll ist dann ist prefer ja gut die ssd ist aber 500 gd
ist das finde ich ist cool das gefällt mir ok nice das das mag ich das gefällt mir wirklich
gut weil das setup ist einfach das setup ist easy du machst im prinzip du machst im prinzip
hier dein festplatten set up ein hör mal auf mit eurem komischen parity rebuild shit
ist überhaupt nichts drauf das finde ich gut das ist das setup ist das setup ist wirklich
easy das ist nice das gefällt mir das gefällt mir mal eine andere frage könnte ich den cash
auch unterteilen dass ich von dieser platte sagen wir mal 250 g für vms verwende und
andere und die anderen 250 für cash oder muss ich die platte komplett nehmen wieso
stoppst du den zink weil ich da eh nichts drauf kopiere was irgendwie wichtig ist ich
stoppt den zink weil der elf stunden im hintergrund rödeln und das jetzt nichts für ein stream
ist ja da bin ich bin ich so sicher die vms liegen per default auf dem cash achso
ok das war jetzt tools vms wie kann man überhaupt vms einschalten settings vm manager enable
vms yes apply nice ok wir haben vms eingeschaltet vms du hast auf deinem android deine home assistant
vm ich habe meine home assistant vm auf einer ubuntu kiste die hier hinten steht so was
machen wir denn jetzt vm ach ja nice nice sagt mal seit wann sieht android eigentlich so aus
wie es aussieht ich habe mal vor 2 3 jahren video dazu gesehen das hat die oberfläche
irgendwie anders aus ist das irgendwie neu designt worden erst vor einer weile da war
das so silber grau die oberfläche mal altes youtube video gucken oberfläche wobei oder
so ne so genau so sah das aus ja so grau ok was legen wir an wir legen den debian an gibt
es den debian debian autostart yes debian keine ahnung test vm oh das finde ich gut
da muss man keine isos runterladen man kann es direkt über das guim machen oder läd es
im hintergrund runter ne ok nein nein macht er nicht ich habe miss erzählt macht er nicht
null weh ok cpus kriegt die vm 4 stück sollte reichen man braucht isos initial memory 4g
ja ja wunderbar perfekt perfekt ok man muss isos installieren ok wo kommen isos hin schares isos
ah ich habe einen samba share mit isos oder was nee flash wie schaere ich das jetzt ach
hier export yes apply auf der anderen seite ach hier isos ich finde das ist hübsch gemacht
ganz ehrlich ist bis jetzt gefällt mir das gut hätte ich gar nicht gedacht ich habe
ja bisher immer so einen bogen drum gemacht habe ich mir gedacht warum soll ich das benutzen
ich habe meine ubuntu kiste und macht den kram selbst drauf aber ich bin ja schon seit
den letzten 2 3 jahren so auf dem trip dass ich alles was ich irgendwie nicht selber machen
muss auch nicht selber mache weil ich keinen bock habe mich mehr um meine infrastruktur
daheim zu kümmern als um alles andere also ist das ich bis jetzt finde ich eigentlich
echt sind ich durchdacht gemacht ja muss ich sagen wir machen jetzt mal den richtigen
hacker man shit leute iso debian iso mal gucken ob das hier funktioniert download images party
tp office official stable release amd 64 ist die richtige guck mal wir machen jetzt richtigen
hacker shit mal gucken ob das funktioniert terminal cd mnt und jetzt was disk isos isos
weget von wegen windows share so ist doch viel besser wir wegetten uns das einfach direkt
aus dem internet und jetzt gehen wir noch mal vms add vm debian so autostart yes so test
vm cpu haus ja vier cpu ist alles in ordnung wunderbar 4g ram iso da ist es debian net install
iso sata ja wunderbar primary disk location ach jetzt verstehe ich hier kann man das auswählen
hier kann man auswählen was er machen soll cash manual ah ok cash was macht der denn
bei auto auto aber warum kann ich dann überhaupt cash auswählen ok wie groß soll das ganze
sein 40g ah das ist dann wenn man das als cash hat dann muft er das auch irgendwann
auf die disks unten drunter niemals auto nehmen der macht nur schlicht das jetzt recht auf
auto um zu gucken aber scheiße macht gut wir wollen also ich vermute jetzt einfach mal
wenn es ein bisschen kvm ist jetzt war bedeutet das image wird 40 gigabyte angelegt und die
kuku die wächst mit der zeit je nachdem wie viel drinne ist wenn das so ist wie normalerweise
unter linux ok unrate share aber man kann direkt den inhalt der vm scheren warum nicht
oh leute ich kann meine grafikkarte durchreichen oder wie sehe ich das richtig kann ich hier
meine grafikkarte pass pass truen wenn ich will ich meine das wird mit meinem bmc nicht
funktionieren aber passt schon soundkarten an mega trance alles klar ach hier kann man
auch pci geräte durchreichen das müssen wir gleich ausprobieren ich habe hier noch
einen alten kombi stick liegen den verwende ich nicht mehr das testen wir gleich mit dem
durchreichen ob das funktioniert start 4m creation jess post jam ho ho bamm dann kein
graphical install install das geht aber gut das finde ich finde ich schick german please
finde ich nicht schlecht gewinnt vielleicht keinen preis für aber schlicht und funktionell
ja die sind vnc viewer verwendet proxmox glaube ich auch es ist ein standard ding das haben
ganz viele ich glaube sogar hetzer verwendet das für ihr wenn du cloud ansicht vor allem
hast hostname debian ja sehr gut domain name keck nee wir lassen es frei 1 2 3 4 5 6 1 2 3 4 5 6 bestes password full username cute chat nee wir schreiben das einfach nur cute wir schreiben das klein sonst kann ich bis nachher nicht merken 1 2 3 4 5 6 1 2 3 4 5 6 you select your time zone central
ist central
samoa eastern kakona kakona time zones
use entire disk
ja ja mach
time zones hell yeah yes
ja dadurch dass es auf die ssd geht flutscht das halt dementsprechend
ne leute hier ist ganz schön warm drinne weil ich weil ich die surferkiste hinter mir rum hab
schauen wir doch mal kann ich jetzt hier umschalten ja nice schauen wir doch mal kurz was so die
auslastung macht nur das juckt es nicht großartig 24 gb ram docker container müssen wir auch ausprobieren
können wir nebenbei machen docker who am i container hinter das ist so der einfachste container um
es um was zu testen docker wie machen wir das hier drüber ich meine die alternative ist man macht sich eine vm und docker compose gedönst drauf oder kann man direkt docker compose hier drauf machen
irgendjemand hat auch gesagt ich soll community apps mal ausprobieren installee community apps mache ich mache ich jetzt nur mal hier wie das standardmäßig vom handling her ist template
an rate net was ist an an rate net
ah ok
ja ich installiere ja community addons user templates plop achso ja das ist das was ich
meiner vor allem einmal angeklickt habe vorhin zynk die default templates so naam heck weh
was
nein an germany please miros ja alles gut so und jetzt kann man sagen hier oder trage ich jetzt hier das docker repo rein
wahrscheinlich und wie mapp ich jetzt wie mapp ich jetzt den port hier ok das ist ja nicht so schön
port ja ja unbedingt container port 80 host port 80 80 tcp and apply ok das ist aber sehr rudimentär
leute wenn noch einer community apps schreibt dann hört auf hier ich habe sehr langsam verstanden dass
ich die community leute soll ich die community apps installieren meint ihr ich sollte community apps
installieren ja genau ok ist das jetzt gestartet ok das heißt auf port 80 80 kriege ich jetzt mein
who am i container who am i nice ok das war gar nicht so kompliziert und wie löschen stehen jetzt
wieder remove yes das war doch gar nicht so schlimm ok debian den naur ssh server ja
glaube es geht los die wir dem salvat installiert debian standardmäßig desktop mit wo kommen wir
denn dahin schon immer ist mal wie lange ich kein debian net install mehr drauf gehauen habe
die net install hat doch noch nie standard mission desktop mit installiert
jetzt bitte gentoo ist es gentoo oder gentoo was braucht der server an strom kann ich nicht
sagen wahrscheinlich gerade mit den laufenden platten wahrscheinlich irgendwie 40 50 watt oder
so deswegen nehme ich den ja auch nicht mehr ich habe meine acht watt low power intel kiste wenn
die platten runtergefahren sind und gut ist ja eigentlich ausrangiert ich habe gedacht hierfür
ist es mal ganz praktisch so gut während debian installiert mache ich jetzt endlich mal das mit
den community addons wie geht das plugins install plugins unrate unrate community apps das da
irgendjemand hat mir doch gerade was zu github geschickt oder irgendjemand hatte mir ja genau
irgendjemand hat mir das hier github geschickt gerade und was was ist das jetzt ist das werbung
für sich selbst ist das eigenwerbung oder was was bin ich was bin ich was bin ich sehend
ja aber warum sollte ich dann was ist der unterschied zwischen diesem github link und
und dem kram hier ok debian ist am start sehr schön cute 123 456 ip add was hat das ding für
eine ip 36 ok 236 gut 1 2 3 2 2 1 3 6 yes habe ich vertippt nice ok wir sind auf unserem debian
ab install mal gucken wie schnell wir sind das muss ich jetzt ausbringen ja ist gut sudo
alter debian ist so old school wahnsinn wobei ganz ehrlich sudo ist auch der letzte dreck
wenn man sich anguckt dass es glaube ich zwei sicherheitsrücken gab in den letzten zwei
jahren mit sudo root exploits da ist es vielleicht sogar besser so ok install pv so mal gucken
wie schnell wir hier sind auf der vm def 0 halb nach pv nach blub punkt bin ja man merkt
halt wir sind auf einer ssd ne also mit dem speed bin ich in einer vm durchaus zufrieden
kann man sich nicht beschweren webseite vom entwickler ok sollte ich sollte ich nicht
eigentlich eine ach so ich habe blubpunkt bin erstmal löschen ok also kommen wir mal
zu community addons nur mal dass ich das richtig verstehe plugins ungleich community addons
oder plugin community applications das ist ein plugin für community applications ach
verstehe also sprich ok ich glaube jetzt habe ich es gecheckt also sprich das hier sind
quasi die offiziellen plugins die es gibt und ein plugin davon ist community applications
das heißt wenn ich hier nach community suche sollte ich irgendwo community applications
finden und was jetzt was macht man da unten aha ok jetzt jetzt habe ich glaube ich kapiert
ok installation ok das ist quasi das gegenstück zu sudo in bash gepiped alles klar und jetzt
install plugin install ach so macht man das ok warum haben die nicht jetzt mal dofe frage
warum haben die nicht hierfür man die haben doch offensichtlich auf ihrer webseite ein
depot warum ist das nicht integriert warum haben die nicht einfach hier eine suche gemacht
dass man hier die offiziellen plugins durchsuchen kann das ist doch ein überflüssiger schritt
oder naja gut install parts ab kommt mit dem nächsten update ok dann
so community ups f5 ja ok hier install plugins ach und hier jetzt auf apps oder wie disclaimer
ja gut aber nur wenn ich das jetzt mal verstehe das da was man jetzt hier drinne sieht hat
nichts damit zu tun also das da ist ein plugin mit einem eigenen store quasi ich nenne es
mal store und das hier ist quasi der offizielle plugin store wahrscheinlich gibt es überschneidung
vermute ich ich kann mich mit ich kann das über mich selbst installieren oder was ach
das ist das gleiche dafür ach so ach ja ach jetzt verstehe ich ok das ist ein ok du installierst
du installierst dieses plugin und das ist quasi ein plugin schrägstrich schrägstrich
community app manager aha ok nice was gibt es denn da so backup also ordentlich was dabei
so und da soll ich jetzt mal nach docker suchen hat er chat gesagt der docker compose manager
was für dinger nein nein nein gibt es da irgendeinen link zu github wie sieht es mit
nem gui aus ach ne hat kein gui ne ich hasse portena geh mal bloß weg sind die platten
eigentlich verschlüsselt ne oder ach ja leute wie siehts eigentlich mit verschlüsselung
aus wie sieht das eigentlich mit mit platten verschlüsselung aus wie wie wie macht man
das ich will ja meine platten natürlich verschlüsselt haben logisch ok ich habe ja noch nichts auf
den platten drauf kann ich das jetzt kann ich das nachträglich machen ja ich weiß es
gibt das hier muss neues array erstellen ok also ach das machst du beim erstellen des
arrays ok also kommando zurück array stoppen ich brauche hier die platten wieder array stoppen
bosschamp kann man das ja eigentlich zugucken was da so treibt ok also machen wir wieder
zu also unassign no device no device ne wie erstelle ich denn jetzt ein neues array debian
ist rib ne der debian liegt doch auf dem cache dachte ich was ist jetzt mit dem debian
passiert ne gute frage es läuft nicht mehr ne ja wie die das genau machen mit ausfallsicherheit
habe ich auch nicht verstanden wie wie sage ich dem jetzt dass ich ein neues array machen
will mit verschlüsselung wie geht das soll ich noch mal new config machen dass dann
alles weg ist ich meine es ist ja eh noch nichts drauf ok wie war das tools new config
yes will ich apply main ok das wie sage ich dem jetzt dass ich verschlüsselung machen
will das muss ich das muss ich ja hier irgendwie
settings settings und dann irgendwie was encryption ne wie würde ich das jetzt machen
ich leg doch gerade ein neues array an settings disk settings n ne ne so schonmal net new config
habe ich schon gemacht new config habe ich gerade schon gemacht new config sieht jetzt
so aus aber wie wähle ich denn jetzt aus dass ich encrypten will oder habe ich nicht
new config genug new config gemacht ne habe ich doch array has been reset beim formatieren
wählt man das aus ah ok das heißt ich lasse das jetzt so und sage start und dann fragt
er mich ob ich formatieren will oder ne ok she baited ok hä kennste
auf disk ok das ist jetzt durchaus verwirrend encryption ok tools new config array must
be stopped habe ich doch gerade schon gemacht proceed du musst das pro pro disk machen
aber muss das filesystem umstellen ok ok ok probieren ok ich mach das jetzt noch mal
tool new config jawoll yes ich will das machen apply hat er es jetzt gemacht ja unassigned
ok unassigned also cache den da ich will eine disk und ich will eine parity und wo
let's start let's she baited mich wieder ich sag's euch ach ich muss disk ich hätte
jetzt disk 1 anklicken müssen dann stoppen wir das wieder gleich ja kennst du ok stop
ok gucken wir uns dann jetzt gehe ich nicht auf parity sondern auf disk 1 wenn er gestoppt
hat ok ja gut das muss man halt wissen ja man ist das ausbaufähig so disk ach filesystems
typ xfs encrypted leute da wäre ich im leben nicht drauf gekommen alter keck wait
x4 gibt's nicht x4 is overrated she baited anscheinend dann so muss ich jetzt muss ich
jetzt ich muss noch passwörter und so einstellen muss jetzt bei der parity auch noch machen
nee parity parity na gut parity ist ja egal von der idee her wenn es verschlüsselt darauf
ist es ist auf der parity wahrscheinlich auch verschlüsselt weil weil verschlüsselte
daten halt rüber gesunken werden irgendwie so wo gebe ich jetzt mein hier hier mache
ich mal ein passwort keyfile passphrase 123456 huge massive passphrase cache ah den cache
müssen auch noch verschlüsselt natürlich btfs encrypted nee da muss ich ja ach so
warum hat er mal eine doofe frage warum hat er btfs für den cache warum hat er btfs für
den cache und nicht xfs für vm snapshots für einfache vm snapshots oder was ist der
hintergrund hat es einen sinn lasst es jetzt halt so ok cash cash cash 123456 123456 reise
fs war das nicht der typ der im knast sitzt ist der typ nicht im knast weil er seine frau
umgebracht hat der reise fs entwickelt hat ich glaube schon reise fs hans reiser ja er
ist hauptsächlich durch das nach ihm benannte reise fs bekannt worden dass er mit seiner
Mitarbeitern blabla er wurde wegen des Mordes an seiner Ehefrau verurteilt da geht es ab
das sagt mal einer in der Open Source Szene passiert nichts MonkaS ja so schauen wir mal
ob ich das jetzt richtig gemacht habe Leute wenn ich jetzt wenn ich jetzt auf start drücke
dann verschlüsselt er das mit meiner pass phrase oder muss ich noch irgendwelche anderen
super special Sachen machen start nein unmountable volume not encrypted
jetzt jetzt halt noch formatieren ich hoffe da standardmäßig nicht drin dass die komplette
dass die komplette platte überschrieben wird weil dann dauert es lange was ich nicht brauche
weil auf der platte ist nichts drauf was macht denn an rate so genau bin ich mir da auch nicht
sicher habe ich mir nicht durchgelesen der chat hat aber gesagt ich soll mir das unbedingt
mal angucken wir haben es geschafft so jetzt noch den cash nice okay wir haben es geschafft
parity cancel gehen wir proceed brauchen wir nicht alles klar nice hat funktioniert ich
bin begeistert so und jetzt ist der kram verschlüsselt das würde ja auch bedeuten wenn ich reboote
muss ich erst einmal mein password eingeben bevor er den kram mounten kann sehe ich das
richtig ja was was hat er hier für schmerzen naja nur testzwecke nur testzwecke ist das
wie startet man da neu ich meine ich kann reboot hier oben drüber machen wie würde
man dann wie startet man dann offiziell neu ach hier unten reboot proceed server is going
down firefox gucken wir ihm mal zu gucken wir gucken ihm mal zu off login launch open
dieses hässliche java ding mein gott ist das schlecht run so hier java stells rebooting
ich meine der reboot ist ganz schön langsam was ich bin erst eine stunde kann doch gar
nicht sein ach so eine stunde seitdem ich restarted hab ja weil insgesamt bin ich schon
deutlich länger am start 222 stunden 45 oder so da sind wir und du dachtest deine super
mikro java kvms kakene ich glaube ganz ehrlich die neue eitrack sachen von dell mit html 5
konsolen so sind durchaus erträglich aber dieses dieses olle zeug ist wirklich einfach
nur räudig schlecht nein schunas habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert aber ich bin kein
großer fan von zfs im heimbereich ich hatte es eine weile am start und so cool so cool
zfs ist vor allem mit dem ganzen mit den ganzen zfs und linux features die dazugekommen sind
dass du disk encryption dabei hast ich glaube du kannst mittlerweile sogar dein dein array
erweitern und sowas muss man sich trotzdem mit zfs beschäftigen also wenn das irgendwie
mal nicht geht und du willst dann mal einfach mal wieder was runter kopieren schnell dann
viel spaß auf der kommando zeile erste mal in ruhe das den pool importieren dann erstmal
den kram mountain und sonst was das ist gar nicht so easy deswegen bin ich finde ich zfs
im heimbereich gar nicht so tolle weil du dich damit beschäftigen muss und ahnung davon
haben muss dass wenn es wirklich mal knallt du nicht komplett hilflos dasteht was bringt
eigentlich disk encryption wenn es nicht vor dem boot abgefragt wird ich gehe davon aus
dass es vor dem boot abgibt also näher nicht vor dem boot ich gehe davon aus dass es vor
dem mountain abgefragt wird da gehe ich gehe ich von auf weil ansonsten würde das nichts
bringen so Android wo sind wir denn jetzt 2.128 da sind wir guckt und hier wird es jetzt
wahrscheinlich abgefragt ja missing passphrase so 1 2 3 4 5 6 ok wenn ich start drücke und
keine passphrase ab geht es erst gar nicht was passiert wenn ich die falsche wenn ich
die falsche falsche passphrase eintrage dann müsste mir eigentlich sagen tut nicht
wrong key ok passphrase also das ui könnte man schon ein bisschen schicker machen start
ist halt der vorteil dass es vom usb booted password feil auf encrypted festplatte ja
wozu da muss ja trotzdem passphrase eingeben falls dann fertig aufgesetzt ist mit docker
container nvidia gpu support für docker muss ich mir mal überlegen war ich gerade nicht
aber ich komme ich komme darauf zurück sollte ich mal gucken wollen ok wir canceln das wieder
also das ist doch nett also ich muss sagen das gui ist sicherlich keine augenweite aber
alles was ich bisher sehe finde ich schon in ordnung so wir haben den cache wir haben
verschlüsselte platten jetzt machen wir noch mal den share mein share ist natürlich weg
den ich vorhin angelegt habe share name 0w use cache pool prefer cache alles klar add
share schau dir mal community apps an das fängst du auch schon an der chat hat mir
schon seit 3000 mal geschrieben community aber ich habe community app schon installiert
hier guck da kannst du auch den keyfile übers netzwerk bereitstellen ich weiß ja nicht
dann musst du das keyfile unencrypted auf irgendeine andere kiste lassen so yes export
und dann das bedeutet ich habe jetzt wieder ein 0w ordner in denen ich ziemlich zackig
kopieren kann nice also ich muss sagen ich das setup mag ich das ist ziemlich simpel
man kann sowas selbst bauen es gibt beispielsweise die möglichkeit mit big cache hieß das ganze
glaube ich wisst ihr habt ihr eine ahnung wie die wie die wie die das im hintergrund
machen habt ihr eine ahnung wie die das im hintergrund machen also ich kenne das hier
wo man zum beispiel eine ssd als cache verwenden kann für normale platten habt ihr eine ahnung
wie die das machen mit dem cache ob die das vielleicht auch damit machen unrate cache
wie die das unter der haube machen gucken wir doch mal wir gucken einfach mal gucken
einfach mal wie ging das jetzt noch mal wenn ich blk id ist es glaube ne krypto lux ne
deffmapper sd f1 sd f1 krypto lux das kann ja nicht sein ich muss ja das eigentlich gemapte
device haben btr fs deffmapper das hier sd f1 ja gut das ist btr fs aber wie machen die
das wie machen die das mit dem cache das wird mich wirklich interessieren ja ist schöner
wie machen die das mit dem cache unrate how caches work in meinem prinzip ist es ja frontend
für x für jede menge open source geschichte würde mich interessieren wie die das gemacht
haben die haben so einen mover ja gut aber die müssen ja irgendwas gebaut haben oder
ist der cache ist die samba konfig einfach nur jetzt muss es mal kurz gtc samba smb smb
konf shares konf lolw nach mnt user ah ok das geht was ist denn mnt user mnt user ist
s h fs was ist denn s h fs ne das ist irgendwas anderes das ist irgendwas anderes das kann
nicht das sein was da steht das ist irgendwie so ein overlay ding hier
ok das müsste man muss jetzt nicht jetzt machen aber muss ich mich mal interessieren muss
ich mal gucken wie die das wie die das machen das das interessiert mich weil es muss ja
so sein dass die sachen erstmal in cache gehen und dann rübergemoved werden das heißt
worauf wird das an wird wird das zeug kopiert samba share hat man ja gesehen geht anscheinend
auf den cache direkt interessant müssen wir mal schauen oder oder ist das wirklich einfach
easy mode die haben ein shell script was im hintergrund die feils ruft irgendwie alle
fünf minuten ne das so einfach kann es nicht sein du musst ja warten bis feils fertig
geschrieben sind und so zeug und dann einfach zu sagen wenn platte voll ist dann muven so
einfach ist es nicht ich probiere das einfach nur aus ich überlege mir vielleicht ob ich
verwende ja ok mnt isos ne wo war das jetzt nochmal mnt cache cache disk ne es war mnt
user ne mnt user isos da ist es weget debian da haben wir den net installer gut so also
das haben wir schon mal gecheckt wie das funktioniert ich muss sagen ich finde es nett gemacht also
ich muss muss echt muss muss die wirklich loben ich finde das schön ich finde das besser
als ich es mir vorgestellt habe so wir legen jetzt noch mal eine vm an und nebenbei gucken
wir uns mal ab apps und und docker gedöns noch mal an also vms weil vms ich habe ja
meine vm gerade gekillt die muss ich jetzt nebenbei noch mal schnell installieren ja
ja vier cpu skibim da kommt es drei reichen auch os debian pucow 40 g rest hat man stand
zu gelassen also ne autostart hatte ich noch gemacht wir nennen es jetzt einfach keg weh
so und jetzt gucken wir uns mal die apps an eine an keine graphical installation hallo
install und jetzt minimieren wir das ein bisschen und gucken dem zu beim install so language
englisch warum gibt es nicht mehr die möglichkeit zu sagen language englisch aber zeitzone
ach nee hier country other europe germany country lokale nee nee ja englische es ist
okay die map german gut was gibt es denn jetzt hier noch für fisch für coole coole
apps also lass mal überlegen ich habe mir okay wir machen jetzt einfach mal die sachen
die ich auch bei mir schon habe wie sieht es wie sieht es mit docker wiki aus haben
wir denn docker wiki jawoll docker wiki easy wie kann ich denn feststellen was ich da jetzt
eigentlich genau installier gibt es da nen link zum repo also sprich wo liegt der source
code von diesem plugin da aber das ist super das finde ich immer doof
support forum projekt ja das kenne ich linux server docker wie ja gut aber das ist nur
ja genau aber woher weiß ich denn jetzt was der hier wirklich installiert ich meine da
muss ja irgendwas machen oder weil irgendjemand muss ja da irgendwie keine ahnung den community
package draus gebaut haben und woher weiß ich was da im hintergrund läuft oder ist das
einfach nur was was die docker registry called oder was linux server docker wiki nein nein
nein nein das ihr versteht nicht was ich meine was da unter dem unter der haubel läuft
ist klar aber woher weiß dieses community app dass es ein docker wiki zum installieren
gibt wisst ihr wie ich meine der kann ja schlecht das komplette docker hab da bereitstellen
das wäre vielleicht ein bisschen viel irgendjemand muss ja gesagt haben es gibt ein docker wiki
zum installieren ist ne xml genau und wo kommt die her und wo liegt die ok ich installier
einfach mal install attention was one or more ports are already in use you will need to
adjust ok ok machen wir also network type bridge ach so ist das das ist quasi nur das was
ich hier selbst machen kann als template im endeffekt so wir nehmen port 80 80 oder port
8000 weil port 80 ist ja hier schon belegt
wie kann ich denn da jetzt könnte ich könnte ich dort einen docker container starten mit
einem reverse proxy drauf der für mich zertifikate macht für meinen unrate kann ich meinem unrate
ordentliche let's encrypt zertifikate verpassen ja ok nice nice ok web 8000 start container
after install probieren wir das mal aus engine x manager swag ok probieren wir mal aus gucken
wir gleich mal ich kann es hier nicht machen weil ich habe ja auch mein api key für cloudflare
nicht aber nur mal so durch nur mal durchklicken und angucken also jetzt sagen wir einfach
mal apply und jetzt sollte ich dann theoretisch auf port 80 80 ein doku wiki laufen haben
donen und woher weiß ich jetzt was läuft hier ach verstehe ach guck mal das hat sogar
eine verlinkung dazu und das finde ich schick das gefällt mir und man kann sogar direkt
den dings ins container das finde ich sehr schick sehr sehr schick dass das das erleichtert
einem das leben tatsächlich das kannst du auch im dashboard sehen ok ach hier so dann
ist schick gefällt mir das ist das das finde ich das finde ich gut gemacht das haben sie
schön gemacht ganz ehrlich ich finde ja ich dachte mir am anfang das ui ist ein bisschen
hängen geblieben aber insgesamt muss ich sagen es ist vielleicht nicht die augen weiter
aber es macht doch einen durchdachten eindruck schick so david grisel benutzt doku wiki als
ein blog ja warum auch nicht man muss doch nicht für alles irgendwelche super krassen
neu modischen statik sei generator und sonst was verwenden und ganz normales wiki reicht
ok jetzt installiert man demian da hier habe ich eine vm übersicht die nicht doch die funktioniert
nein weiter so was hat man dann sonst doch hier interessantes drauf tools web ui was
gibt es denn hier was geh weg irgendwelche php dinger oder ne das in config settings
wahrscheinlich aber wisst ihr was die im backend verwenden habt ihr eine ahnung was mit was
ist dieses diese webseite gemacht also nein also mit was das backend gemacht ist das php
keine ahnung php ok ne juckt mich nicht ehrlich gesagt ach hier kann man update next 6.10 rc2
ok an rate 6.10 wir gucken mal was es da neues gibt ich habe schon gelesen an rate ist basiert
auf slackware das ist wirklich mit die aller allererste slackware basierte sache die ich
jemals im einsatz hatte was eigentlich recht wir können gucken was haben die hier am start
laufen haben den engine x ja den engine x laufen config
hallo flash config darf ich nicht ich brauche immer was liegt my server plugin user profile
und das juckt mich nicht slackware wenn der einzige maintainer stirbt ja remote ok das
ist nichts so spannendes was damit jetzt kommt oder alles direkt unter etc etc engine x
engine x engine x konf php hat das ja auch falsch sites
konf hab websocket past cgi was zum
ww ok keine ahnung yes continue gib ihm ich muss mir dazu keine videos angucken ich kriege
das ja selbst raus vielleicht gucke ich mir videos an wenn ich part 2 was nicht raus
finde und wenns der chat auch nicht weiß so gut mein debian ist wieder am start wo habe
ich jetzt noch mal gesehen was meine vms für eine alpi bekommen hier sieht man das oder
muss ich mich muss ich in der vm gucken wahrscheinlich muss ich in der vm gucken hat 140 also ssh 140
yes yes man ich kann gerade nicht mehr tippen das ist ja debian also ich muss sagen das
fühlt sich durchaus alles sehr geschmeidig und gut an es ist ja auch es ist ja auch
auf eine ssd es ist ja auf dem ssd cash na guck mal hier kath def 0 nach pv 0 w und bin
ja wirklich das ist das geht halt auf die ssd gerade ok nice so vm wunderbar funst so
guck mal was es noch für apps gibt beziehungsweise was man sonst noch so damit treiben kann also
lass mal überlegen doku wiki hat funktioniert ja wie würde ich backups machen zum beispiel
also mal angenommen ich hätte eine usb festplatte mit das das können wir doch simulieren backup
auf us na home assistant muss ich da drauf nicht wirklich ins ach nee ich wollte usb
passthrough funkt ja ja usb usb passthrough usb passthrough wollte ich noch checken kurz
machen wir mal eine debian machen wir die debian vm ls usb nix da und wie mache ich
jetzt usb passthrough btfs send und receive nee nee nee das bringt mir nichts das ist ja xfs und
außerdem kann ich schlecht auf irgendeine cloud geschichte ja doch auf eine usb platte könnte ich
das ja hast schon recht hast du schon mal dockers form gemacht nein dockers form ist auch total
wie soll man sagen so dem tode geweiht es ist eigentlich kubernetes or die mittlerweile kubernetes
so wie mache ich ein usb passthrough edit so ich stöpsel mal kurz usb an ich habe meine
verlängere runter geschmissen leute wat das ist total verknotet es fack meine güte moment ich
muss euch beabstöpseln
jetzt höre ich mich wieder auf der anderen seite nicht alter sekunde leute ich muss euch
kurz ausmachen sonst wird es zu laut ok passt wieder gefixt ich wollte usb stick anstöpseln
es hier wird da auch gestreamt vielleicht nachher wieder ich versuche es heute mal mit
ein bisschen delay ich kann halt nicht viel delay machen im prinzip ist es eigentlich kein delay
oder oder kein stream weil ganz ohne chat interaktions stream habe ich keinen bock also ich werde ich
mache viel das höchste der gefühle ist eine minute delay mehr kann ich nicht machen so usb
devices wie kriege ich mein massiv ja ich habe ich habe also ich fordere mal ein video zuzumachen
youtube auch mal teilhaben lassen ach hier guckt mal nice ach das ui finde ich schick
gibt es im zweifelsfall auch ein wirtmanager addon falls ich noch ein bisschen mehr einstellen
will so hat der passthrough funktioniert da sind wir easy aber ein wirtmanager vielleicht
wirtmanager ok es gibt ein wirtmanager und ein wirtmanager beta ok warum last update
2017 ist vielleicht ein bisschen lang her 2021 das ist deutlich sinniger aber wie kann ich
den wirtmanager denn überhaupt aufmachen weil der wirtmanager brauchen wie mache ich das
denn auf ich lasse mich mal überraschen mal gucken was passiert was zum ok ich lasse einfach
mal die ford ich habe keine ahnung was ist was es macht hat es jetzt installiert hat es
jetzt habe ich das falsche geklickt Leute habe ich das falsche geklickt
install apply aber warum gibt es einen knopf wenn ich den ich drücken darf
download complete ok ja das docker ui ist also das ist so wirklich ein bisschen painstamp
dann finde ich successfully wirtmanager web ui ach so der macht einfach den gnome auf
mit kvm oder sowas ok ok das ist vielleicht ein bisschen overkill den gnome laufen zu
lassen dafür aber why not das ist kein gnome oder da habe ich die kvm das heißt ich kann
sogar mit dem wirtmanager das finde ich tatsächlich eine durchaus schicke idee wenn ich nämlich
ein bisschen wenn ich nämlich ein bisschen mehr option machen will dies nicht im web
ui geht dann würde ich das über die wirtmanager geschichte machen coole sache finde ich gut
irgendwelchen kunden darf ich nicht cancelen da könnte ich jetzt nämlich auch hier direkt
sagen usb redirektion add hardware usb host device und da kann ich hier sachen durchreichen
was ich jetzt nicht mache weil weiß was das wer weiß was das da ist ok schick schick schick
finde ich gut kann ich irgendwie ressourcenverbrauch von dem graben sehen ne das ist konsole x kann
ich kann ich mir ressourcenverbrauch von container container krempele anzeigen lassen hast du
schon einmal auf der arbeit sachen mit kegwebe dann ja habe ich schon habe ich schon ach
moment merken es gibt noch einen advanced view ja viel besser ach ja stimmt wie ist das
mit updates wie ist das mit pack mit mit container updates steht dann hier achtung bitte updaten
oder macht er das ich mache ich hoffe nicht dass das komplett automatisch macht gibt
es hier wahrscheinlich knopf für ich mag portena nicht kann mich da kann mir da nicht
helfen ich will kein auto plug in so ach hier sehe ich doch cpu memory load ja guck
mal geht doch doch doch ok sehr schön sehr schön das finde ich finde es gut also ich
muss sagen gefällt mir wirklich bis jetzt soll wir meinen mal kurz ne runde kripto
currency ja ok jetzt testen wir usb usb backup was würdet ihr empfehlen also mal genommen
ich möchte einfach nur einmal in der nacht ein verzeichnis irgendwie rüber kopieren
paar usb was würdet ihr empfehlen erst wenn ja erst wenn verwende ich aktuell auch erst
wenn ist die die einfachste variante aber ich dachte mir vielleicht gibt es da eben
so eine fertige so eine fertige app für oder oder heißt erst wenn kann man kann man hier
direkt erst machen über das gui was lucky backup lucky klingt so nach dem motto muss
glück haben das ist back up i use this as backend ok 2000 locker hap stars wie sieht
es mit airclone aus für cloud airclone beta 2016 2018 ach nee edit moment edit guck ja
ganz falsch ne aber trotzdem das ist wirklich das müsste denn update müsste das haben
das plugin ist als airclone als command line programm ja gut ja damit könnte ich es natürlich
von hand machen aber erstmal usb festplatte dranhängen sekunde
so also was unassigned device ist er dann unbedingt installieren und du siehst auf main
alle zusätzlichen attached storage kannst du auch in der fs summer network stress mount
was soll ich was soll ich machen das unassigned was unassigned plus unassigned devices is
used to mount and share non a radius ok das ist tatsächlich ganz nützlich ja install
ist tatsächlich ganz nützlich beides installieren ok wenn der chat das sagt
ob sieht das jetzt anders aus ok und nu docker vms ne was macht das was macht das jetzt shares
ok ssd plus format bem dann darf ich nicht darf ich nicht formatieren also ich könnte
hat das hat das nummer bevor ich das jetzt hat es da eingebaute back up sache oder nicht
ud settings wie komm ich in ud settings settings ud hier unten unassigned device settings
destructive mode enabled format xfs encrypted ja natürlich wäre blöd wenn ich mein back
up nicht nicht nicht encrypten würde next yes nein yes also ich muss sagen ich finde
es wirklich nice bisher hätte ich gar nicht gedacht das hat das hat durchaus was ja
etwas finde ich gut ok weiter im text jetzt habe ich hier eine unassigned ssd dran mit
die als kann ich sie noch mounten also sprich von der idee her ich würde das jetzt mounten
und dann nehme ich ein weiteres back up programm was ich mein zum back up konfigurieren benutze
oder wie ok wo hat er das jetzt gemontet woher weiß ich jetzt wo es gemontet ist ach hier
mnt disk sandisk bla bla bla ja ok ok also gut oh mein f was mit dem stream hat das stream
gerade geleckt leute is voter von wieder abkacken frames dropped bock back up gibt es auch bock
matick was das denn konfiguration triffen back up server das habe ich noch eine mal
verwendet also ich würde gerne am liebsten einfach nur was haben wo ich sage dieses verzeichnis
einmal in der nacht auf die usb festplatte kopieren irgendjemand hat gesagt das da keine
ahnung ob das taugt dass das logo sieht schon mal nicht sehr big brain aus aber gut das
sagt er über die software nix aus ja in den erstes ja aber ich bräuchte einen erstes
mit dem kronen oder irgendwas dabei is a very user friendly back up programm it uses
erstens als back end transfer f over only changes the air if you create a crunch or
please be sure to check the console mode checking ok ich installe das mal und dann mache ich
das andere auch noch 80 80 apply ja das mit docker hub results das habe ich schon gecheckt
ja das mit lucky habe ich auch kann das ist das ist für den fall der fälle das nicht
funktioniert kann er sagen dass es ja auch muss halt glück haben er so gibt es nicht
es gibt dir so ein pro es gibt radar sync das ist für offsite back up geschichten für
offsite offsite back up geschichten würde ich das da verwenden das beste ok container
docker back up web ui naja ne ne ne ne da da mache ich da vordel ich netten herum das
ist irgendein cute programm für über vnc ne ne ne ne ne das verwende ich nicht wie schweißt
man wie löscht man das jetzt wieder über den app store oder über dockers die docker
links direkt uns an install actions an install erst schick gemacht das ist besser als das
originale plug in system con geht über settings user scripts ach so settings user scripts
was scheduler vielleicht läuft der container mit dem lucky nein da ist weg ach plug in
user scripts aktuell habe ich auch so con job der einmal in der nacht flub auf usb das
schiebt ich finde schick muss sagen mir gefällt das hat was finde ich finde ich bin ernsthaft
davon überlegen ob ich das nicht vielleicht sogar verwende muss mich weniger drum kümmern
leute wie sieht es mit updates aus wie sieht das mit updates aus also mal für den fall
der fälle ich benutze sagen wir jetzt mal hier irgendwie 55 community apps und ich update
mein android wie oft geht es kaputt also wie oft geht das android update kaputt da würde
ich eigentlich hoffen so nie und wie oft gehen die community apps nicht mehr nachdem android
geupdatet hat es geht immer also mir geht es darum wie oft beispielsweise die community
apps nicht mehr funktionieren nachdem ich android geupdatet habe auch nicht ok das finde
ich das finde ich gut back up was haben wir denn hier schönes zu sehen alter 61 eindreger
hat doch mit back up nichts zu tun offischel offischel bedeutet was bedeutet offischel
bedeutet dass von dem typ der community apps macht oder von unrate hau mal gleich mal drauf
attention port 22 ja gut das brauche ich tatsächlich wenn du per git pushen willst auf jeden fall
wobei lasst was mal weg web ui and get over ja 3000 sehr gut apply also sprich auf port 3000
habe ich jetzt gleich mein git stells am start ans tars da gefühlt ab da ist es nice ja gut
das müssen wir jetzt nicht durchklicken brauchen wir nicht also normalerweise würde ich für
oft seit michael 50 trillionen da ist er wieder wie bekomme ich mein mw2 nuttyp auf offen hab
schon das ist gebetet das ist wieder gebetet der michael 50 milliarden gebetet uns ich
glaube nicht dass er wirklich mw2 port nutt geschichten freigeben muss ansonsten halt
port zweiter leiten welche weiß ich aus dem kopf auch nicht danke für den sub hier f cq
carry out siebwinde und selbst sieben huge subscriptions ja das ist für oft seit würde
ich halt sowas verwenden kann man jetzt mal was anderes kann man die sachen sortieren
lassen nach beliebtheit dass ich zum beispiel gehe backup und sagt dann download download
geschichten kann ich distributed object storage genau das brauche ich für meine erst mal
ich hab cloud angeht wirtschamp und matic hat das ein gui mal ausprobieren
einfacher plan auf gehts
verstehe ist das richtig die meist plug in sind docker images anscheinend ja also du
kannst das ohne problem mit dem also ich habe ja aktuell auf meiner ubuntu kiste einfach
auch in docker compose file und gut ist das ist halt ein bisschen lub freundlicher hier
ja ich bin aber echt eine nübel kann er nix kann er nix schlechtes sagen ok das hat kein
gui github kennen das nicht ah da muss man ok das konfiguriert man über jammel oder
so ok verstehe verstehe install ja wie ich jetzt aber einfach den erst machen der mir
einmal in der nacht die sachen auf den usb gerät kopiert habe ich immer noch nicht
gecheckt ist auch gut ja ich kenne halt ein bisschen besser aber geht in die gleiche richtung
user skript also sprich user skript das da mit diesem old school logo is designed to
be frontend to execute user skript install ok gucken wir mal ich meine im zweifelsfall
könnte ich einfach auf mich also was was was höchstwahrscheinlich einfach funktionieren
würde ist tron tab e oder den kram reinschreiben hast du dich damals kollektiv doch habe ich
so docher containers user skript settings user skript add new skript backup was auch immer
und wie wo will ich jetzt aus was ich für einen skript hinterlege momentan
habe ich das her ich bin verwirrt wo von ks über das zahnrad ach da war da hätte ich
wäre nie drauf gekommen oder der hätt ich das hätt ich das hat das sonntags highlighting
lull lull lull ersönk von ok ok mal gucken ob wir das jetzt hinkriegen ersönk von ok
ich brauche ich brauche ein verzeichnis zum ausprobieren also main also wir machen wir
machen ich ich muss terminal aufmachen also mnt user so weiß was ich isos wir nehmen
einfach isos wir nehmen isos mnt user isos mnt user isos nach ich muss mir die option
gleich noch mal angucken minus v ach du scheiße ersönk sachen backups wollen wir nach mnt
6 zahn disk da soll das hin ok ersönk backup options disk kann ich mir immer nicht merken
aus dem kopf minus r ist recursive ja das brauchen wir minus r und minus v ist anzeigen
dann brauchen wir noch delete ist kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten ob man die sachen
die es nicht mehr gibt im ziel löschen will options z ist glaube ich compress und p ist
genau das will ich haben so ersönk minus minus help ja klar wenn du erst mal 30 seiten
lesen willst bist du durch blick ok save changes und jetzt backup run script fertig dann so
und wenn jetzt alles funktioniert hat sollte ich unter mnt disks zahn disk isos ein backup
haben genau nice man kann das ui nämlich extrem verändern kann man das das sieht ja hässlich
aus ich muss euch das video mal zeigen das ist mega hässlich da plägt ja gar keiner
mehr durch monka es warum sollte ich das warum sollte ich den webinterface so verschandeln
da wüsste ich ja gar nicht mehr was ich anklicken soll ich weiß gar nicht ich weiß gar nicht
was ich hier eigentlich gerade sehe was sehe ich hier überhaupt das sind kategorien wahrscheinlich
tailscale das ist für online backup ne ach nee vpn dann habe ich den jetzt durcheinander
gebracht tailscale sind die mit mit wire guard so die waren das ja gut schedule also sagen
wir mal custom schedule alle fünf minuten alle minuten ist sternchen sternchen sternchen
sternchen sternchen oder schon every minute gucken wir mal ob sternchen sternchen sternchen
sternchen ja genau ist das überhaupt kon-syn-tags die ich da eingeben soll apply hoffe ich mal
so und jetzt können wir nämlich mal testen jetzt können wir mal testen ob das mit dem
backup funktioniert und zwar belegen jetzt mal nach mnt users isos machen wir jetzt einfach
touch blub punkt iso leere datei so und wenn jetzt jede minute den
kronz shop läuft sollte jetzt gleich der kram dort auftauchen in einer minute
lot lock zollack
Danke für den Sub, für den gegifteten Sub, huge, mich einen 5 Spiljaren an Business Raster
als Sub gespendet, sehr schön.
So, gucken wir mal, ob das jetzt funktioniert, irgendwann, demnächst, so, also, das hätten
wir jetzt auch, gibt's sonst noch, chat, gibt's sonst noch irgendwas, was ich ausprobieren
soll?
Mein Backup dauert nicht länger als eine Minute.
Hast du die Änderung mit dem Hetzer Storage schon mitbekommen?
Nein?
Warum?
Was gab's, was gab's für, was gab's für Änderungen?
Ah, guck mal, blubiso, da ist es.
Der Storage gleicher Preis, nice, also, Backup funktioniert, also, Settings, User Scripts,
fahren wir das mal wieder hoch auf, ähm, Daily, Apply, das basiert auf Slackware, also, das
ist das erste und einzige, was ich wahrscheinlich jemals Slackware-basiertes einsetze.
MonkaS, ja, Woodface, ganz schrecklich.
So, ähm, wie ist das bei einem Reboot?
Bei einem Reboot sagen wir, DoCoWiki soll automatisch starten, Githynx soll automatisch
starten, Wirt Manager soll auch automatisch starten, okay.
Nein, nicht wirklich, warum nicht, so, was wollte ich denn sonst noch ausprobieren?
Gibt's sonst noch irgendwas, lasst mal überlegen.
Eigentlich, eigentlich haben wir alles mehr oder weniger ausprobiert.
Ähm, Hetzner, Pricing, schauen wir mal, äh, Storage Prices, 10TB, 487 Euro, immer noch
zu teuer für Offside Backup, das ist immer, das ist definitiv zu teuer für Offside Backup,
Storage Box, ja, ja, können wir auch machen, ja, das ist schon besser, 5TB, 11 Euro, das
ist durchaus in Ordnung und wie verwendet man die, muss man die auf einen schon bestehenden
Server mounten oder wie funktioniert das, habe ich glaube ich noch nie verwendet, ne,
ne, hab ich definitiv noch nicht verwendet, mountet man das auf einen bestehenden Server
oder ist das eine fertige VM oder, oder, was ist das und wie funktioniert das, würdest
du, was würdest du für Backup nehmen, tja, ganz ehrlich, ich finde das durchaus fair,
für 5TB, 11 Euro, kann man sich eigentlich nicht beschweren.
Ja, solange es das H geht, kannst du ja auch R-Sync machen, genau, ja, das finde ich,
das finde ich gut, wobei, ganz ehrlich, ich würde es eher über Borg Backup machen, weil,
ich will es ja verschlüsselt haben, ich will ja nicht, ich will es ja nicht im Klartext
dahin legen.
Offener Nuttyp, komplettes Device Exposed, das stimmt doch überhaupt nicht, das Problem
ist, dass Nuttyp nicht näher definiert ist, aber wenn du einfach nur Ports weiterleitest
auf deine Konsole, sollte dann nicht allzu viel passieren, ach ja, übrigens, Michael
50 Billion, wenn du, was hast du für einen Provider, mir fällt nämlich gerade was ein,
was hast du denn für einen Provider, Vodafone, deutsche Glasfone, hast du einen IPv6 Anschluss
mit DualStack Lite oder hast du einen richtig echten DualStack, also hast du eine, hast
du eine öffentliche IPv4 Adresse, wenn du DualStack Lite hast, ist F in den Chat angesagt
für Michael 50 Billion, weil dann wird das nichts mit Ports weiterleiten auf IPv4, DualStack
Lite kannst du vergessen, DualStack Lite ist nicht möglich, ja, also wenn das DualStack
Lite ist, dann ist vorbei, keine Chance, kannst du nichts machen, du hast Nuttyp auf
Provider Seite, du kannst nicht den Router vom Provider umkonfigurieren, du mein, du
könntest das Tunneln, ja, genau, du könntest das, das ist das nächste, du könntest das
Tunneln, du könntest so eine Art VPN aufbauen und das dann darüber weiterleiten, aber das
ist dann doch ein bisschen komplizierter, ja und du musst deinen Provider abfacken, dass
sie dir echtes DualStack geben, was sie wahrscheinlich nicht machen werden, weil sie zu wenig Adresse
haben, keine Ahnung, da bin ich froh, dass ich Vodafone genervt habe, ich hab ja Vodafone
rum, ich hab ja auch Vodafone so krass rumgespammt auf Twitter, dass das bei mir alles wieder
ordentlich funktioniert, ich hab die, ich hab die öffentlich angeflamed zwei Wochen
lang, als wir mit dem Stream Probleme hatten, Top Anwalt bringt dir da nichts in dem Fall,
je nachdem, was du unterschrieben hast, ja, Leute, soll ich euch irgendwas ausprobieren,
also Fazit muss ich sagen, es ist viel besser, als ich gedacht habe, das hört mir von mir
selten, normalerweise ist es bei mir eher so, dass ich sage, ich hab's euch doch gesagt,
es ist Mist, aber in dem Fall muss ich sagen, ist das Android, finde ich wirklich eine schicke
Geschichte, vor allem die Cache-Config, dass das so einfach ist mit dem Laufwerk, hat mich
überzeugt, finde ich gut, finde ich nice, so jetzt schauen wir, ich reboote mal und wir
schauen mal, wie das jetzt mit den ganzen Apps ist beim Neustarten, schauen wir mal,
reboot, one invalid device, ja, leck mich, wie ist es mit Platten austauschen, wenn die
kaputt geht, Main, machen wir mal, reboot, proceed, das ist, wo ich dich, das ist, das
ist, wo ich dich, aber wenn du einen richtig echten Dual-Stack hast, mit public IPv4-Adresse,
wie soll dann dein Provider noch natt machen, also, oder verstehe ich jetzt nicht, was du
hast, was du meinst, also warum sollte er das, in der Regel ist es ja immer in Kombinationen,
dass alles über IPv6 getunnelt wird zum Provider und der Provider dann quasi einen Ausgang
hat für IPv4, mal gucken, ob jetzt alles hochkommt, wenn wieder gebootet ist, ok, es ist PHP,
jetzt haben wir die Antwort, das ist definitiv PHP, also ganz ehrlich, ein Docker-Cluster,
je nachdem, was du daheim betreiben willst, also ich wüsste jetzt so pauschal nichts,
wofür ich das verwenden würde, außer halt zum Üben oder zum Basteln, um des Basteln-Willens,
aber sag mal ein Beispiel, also was würdest du zum Beispiel in einem Raspberry Pi Cluster
daheim laufen lassen, achso, jetzt kommt gleich der Kubernetes Cluster oder sowas, das ist
aber die nächste Frage, wozu brauchst du daheim ein Kubernetes Cluster?
Aha, der Begriff wird falsch sein, aber wenn du dir dein Provider-Dualstack verkaufst,
bist du trotzdem V4-CG-nuttet, äh, warum sollte man bei IPv4-6-Carrier-Create-nutt machen,
verstehe nicht, um mal ganz nach vorne ab zu gehen, also spätestens wenn ich Ports weiterleiten
kann bei mir und ich von außen rankomme, dann kann ich nicht hinter einem Carrier-Create-nutt
sein, egal, kann ich jetzt nicht so ganz folgen, aber ok, ja was war denn jetzt diese Sache
hier mit dem, hier, ja bei mir ist es halt auch zum Üben und weil ich mal wissen will,
ja dann, natürlich, dann mach nur zu, dann nehmt ihr drei, denkt dran ein Cluster sollte
in der Regel drei Knoten haben, nicht nur zwei, stellt ihr drei Raspberry-Piles hin
und bastelt, sprich doch überhaupt nichts dagegen, gib ihm, so Leute, ist es wieder
oben, da ist es, Start, Keyphrase 123456, Start, Hallo, 123456, Start, ah das war jetzt
für die Sandisk, ne die Sandisk muss ich nochmal angeben wahrscheinlich, warum drei
und nicht drei, hä, also warum drei und nicht zwei, damit du entscheiden kannst, welcher
Knoten tot ist und welcher nicht, also du brauchst ja, also stell dir mal vor du hast
zwei Cluster-Knoten und die Verbindung bricht weg zwischen den beiden Cluster-Knoten, dann
sehen die sich gegenseitig nicht mehr und jeder von beiden denkt, dass er der aktive
ist, im Zweifelsfall hast du dann quasi deine Primary-IP auf beiden Knoten anlegen, was du
nicht haben willst, deswegen kannst, deswegen machst du in der Regel zwei, zwei, also mindestens
drei Knoten, einer davon muss nicht zwangsläufig ein echter Knoten sein, sondern reicht, wenn
der mit entscheidet, welcher aktiv wird und welcher nicht, so, Mount, muss ich nochmal
Passwort eingeben wahrscheinlich, äh, warum konnte ich jetzt meine Sandisk mounten ohne
Passwort einzugeben, obwohl die encrypted ist, wahrscheinlich weil ich am Anfang das
gleiche Passwort verwendet habe oder, Passwort wurde gecasht, im Main-System oder wie, also
besprechen, wenn ich das entsperre, dann ist das an, ja ok, ja ne, Docker-Cluster macht
man heute nicht, das ist richtig, im Prinzip ist es Kubernetes oder, äh, kann es sich
verbuddeln gehen, also man muss gar nicht mit Docker Swarm oder sowas anfangen, welches
Linux benutzt du eigentlich, das ist Manjaro Linux mit i3-WM, ja Leute, also Fazit, Unrate,
mir gefällt das viel besser, als ich im Vorfeld gedacht habe, das mit dem Cache zum einrichten
finde ich nice, die Community-App-Geschichte ist nice, wenn ihr jetzt nicht noch irgendwelche
super tollen Community-Apps habt, die ich mir mal angucken sollte, äh, was, Docker Service
not enabled, ah, ich hab meine Array nicht gestartet, ich loop, äh, äh, was, was, ok,
ok.
Du hast kein Auto Start aktiviert, doch habe ich, ich habe aber anscheinend nicht richtig
gemountet, wie es aussieht.
Und jetzt sind die, ach jetzt sind die VMs am Start, die Container am Start.
Gehen Snapshots, das ist eine gute Frage, gehen Container Snapshots, das ist tatsächlich
interessant, weil ich, es ist ja BTRFS auf dem Cache, kann man Container Snapshots machen
und kann man VM beziehungsweise kann man Container Snapshots machen, das ist eine gute Frage,
ja, ja, müssen wir tatsächlich mal schauen.
Kann man Snapshots machen?
Stop?
Nee, anscheinend nicht.
Kann man nicht.
Das wäre, das ist doof, es wäre aber auf jeden Fall cool, wenn das geht.
Das wäre wirklich äußerst POG, wenn das funktioniert.
Wofür ist das jetzt gut?
Das ist ein Webinterface, wo du deine, dein Storage mit verwalten kannst, bloß extra
Kram.
Du kannst das alles auch selbst machen mit irgendeinem Debian oder Ubuntu Server und
dein Kram drauf installieren, klar.
Wieso nutzt du nicht Proxmox?
Ich verwende auch kein Unraid, guck mir das an.
Proxmox habe ich mir angeguckt, es gab ein paar Sachen, die mir nicht so gefallen haben,
aber insgesamt, also insgesamt fand ich das Produkt nicht schlecht.
Ich kann mich jetzt gar nicht mehr richtig dran erinnern, wir haben Proxmox zwei Mal ausprobiert.
Das Containerhandling hat mir nicht wirklich gefallen, sodass ich am Ende doch wieder
eine VM installiert hätte, mit Docker Compose oder sowas dabei.
Ja, also Michael5Spieljahn, wenn du hinter CarrierCrateNuts sitzt, kannst du nichts machen
in einer Fritzbox.
Das müssen wir jetzt erstmal rauskriegen.
Die Minikube probieren wir jetzt nicht.
Worauf mein Server aktuell basiert, ich habe dazu ein Video gemacht vor nicht all zu langer
Zeit, wo ich ein paar Sachen zeige.
Es ist ein Ubuntu Server mit Docker Compose und fertig, also eine KVM, VM mit Home Assistant
drauf habe ich noch.
Hier habe ich das ganze Zeug mal ein bisschen gezeigt in einem Video.
Also, wenn du DualStack Lite hast, dann bekommst du nur eine IPv6 Adresse und über diese IPv6
Verbindung wird dein kompletter IPv4 Traffic zum Provider getunnelt und dort geht er dann
quasi aus mit einer Public IP, die sich mehrere Kunden beim Provider teilen, raus.
Und deswegen kannst du keine Ports weiter leiten, solltest du DualStack Lite haben mit CarrierCrateNut.
So, ich weiß nicht, ob das der Fall ist, das kann ich dir nicht sagen, aber wahrscheinlich
ist es der Fall und wenn du CarrierCrateNut hast, kannst du nichts machen daran, kannst
du keine Ports weiter leiten, außer mit irgendwelchen Tunnelgeschichten.
So, aber Leute, es reicht, genug geschwätzt, ich war glaube ich jetzt vier Stunden orten
oder sowas.
Unrate nutzen?
Ganz ehrlich, ich bin echt am überlegen, ob ich nicht mal eine Ubuntu Kiste damit ablöse.
Ich haue mir das drauf, mache eine Cache, ich habe ja sogar eine SSD drinne, das System
läuft vom USB Stick, ich nehme die SSD als Cache, mache die Platten rein für Parity und
Disk 1, mache einmal nachts Backup, fertig.
Kannst du noch eben den NGINX Proxy Manager angucken?
Der Patrick hat auch gesagt, ich soll mal irgendwie, was soll ich mir angucken, Swag?
Nee, vom USB Stick ist richtig gut, das läuft komplett im Rahmen, selbst wenn der USB Stick
kaputt geht, läuft es weiter, Swag, was soll ich mir angucken, Proxy Manager, das da, Traffic
habe ich jetzt aktuell als Reverse Proxy am Start, ach das da, ja das kenne ich, das
kenne ich, ne ne doch, das kenne ich, da kann man dann auch DNS-Authentifizierung machen
und sowas, die Sache ist nur die, wie würde ich es jetzt hinbekommen, dass mein Unrate
selber dahinter steht, gar nicht, also doch, würde ich hinbekommen, aber erst nachdem
ich mich einmal ohne HTTPS eingeloggt habe und mein Passwort eingegeben habe für mein
Rate, weil vorher starten die Docker Container nicht und bevor die Docker Container nicht
waren, startet auch mein Nginx Proxy Manager nicht, Leute, ich mache jetzt Schluss, zu
lange gelabert, zu wenig getrunken wieder, wir sehen uns, wir sehen uns, bis nächstes
Mal, mach alles gut, see you.